Someone was screaming inside the incinerator.
The year was 1975.
The location was a top secret refinery and
waste disposal plant, one of the many front
organizations owned and operated by the SCP
Foundation.
This sprawling facility, separated into three
different huge units, each with a specialized
task, was located around 75 kilometers outside
of Summer Springs, Colorado.
It had operated for several decades without
incident, but today, all hell was about to
break loose.
Alarms were blaring in Unit C, the area of
the facility that dealt with destroying non-anomalous
waste via incineration.
A traumatized worker had pulled the emergency
lever near one of the incinerators in a panic
when he’d first heard the loud banging against
the interior walls, and then, those horrific,
pained wails.
That’s when the workers of Unit C came to
a horrifying realization: The screams weren’t
just coming from one of the incinerators in
Unit C, they were coming from all six.
A chorus of absolute agony, echoing up out
of the ash pits.
This was impossible, as far as the Unit C
staff were concerned.
These incinerators were only to be used for
confirmed non-anomalous material - could some
animals or even some poor workers somehow
fallen into the incinerators?
But even if they had, what were the odds that
someone had fallen in all six of them at once?
It was impossible.
The Site Director was immediately brought
in to authorize an investigation, at which
point he demanded that at least one of the
furnaces - in this case, Furnace Number 4
- be shut off so researchers and guards could
investigate what was going on inside.
It seemed like the obvious course of action,
but for some of the people on site that day,
this would prove to be a fatal mistake.
When the fires were put out, something started
rattling in the disposal chute.
There was a scratching and squealing noise,
like something scraping up against the metal.
A maintenance worker was ordered to go check
inside, and when he opened the hatch, he let
out a bone-chilling shriek.
There was something - or was it someone?
- climbing back up the disposal chute.
It emerged from the darkness, backlit by the
still-burning embers of the incinerator, letting
out an awful, screeching noise that could
make even a hardened Mobile Task Force operative
shake with fear.
The creature was humanoid, a charred, mutilated
skeleton, reaching out towards the maintenance
worker with a bony claw.
Before the worker had a chance to stumble
back in horror, the beast had clasped him
by the throat and started to squeeze.
It didn’t even need to strangle him - the
heat of its skeletal hand burned away the
worker’s throat in seconds, leaving his
limp, wheezing body to drop to the metal grate
of the platform below him.
Several armed guards and maintenance workers
moved forward to fend off the monster, but
just then a volley of more violent shrieks
echoed out of the chute behind it.
It only took seconds for over a dozen more
creatures to crawl out of the disposal chute.
They were all like the first - people at various
stages of incineration, some were glowing,
charred skeletons with barely any flesh, others
looking more like severe burn victims, their
faces contorted into scowls of hate and rage.
The assembled guards opened fire on the sudden
influx of anomalies, emptying the magazines
of their submachine guns into the burning
bodies, but their weapons didn’t seem to
cause any lasting damage.
The bullets would tear through the flesh of
the creatures, causing some of them to stumble
and fall, but the wounds would close and the
creatures would rise again.
It seemed they possessed a deadly combo of
extremely high aggression, and incredible
regenerative abilities.
None of the staff present in Unit C were safe
as the burned corpses attacked anyone they
could find with their bare hands, beating
and biting and clawing.
Many of them would grapple with Foundation
personnel, latching on to them and trying
to pull them back down into the incinerator
with them.
These creatures that would later be known
as SCP-2419-A caused several fatalities with
their surprise attack that day, and the situation
was only brought back under control when a
Mobile Task Force that possessed more advanced
training and weaponry was dispatched to the
location.
Despite orders from the Site Director, the
MTF found it impossible to actually terminate
any of the entities due to their regenerative
abilities.
Instead, the MTF agents focused on forcing
the anomalies back into the chute of Incinerator
Number 4 using a powerful industrial steam
lance.
Once they were back inside, the incinerator’s
burners were started up once again.
The MTF were also able to capture five of
the entities and detain them for questioning
and experimentation, finally bringing this
unexpected containment breach to an end.
The Foundation is an organization that prides
itself on possessing forbidden and secret
knowledge, but even they had no idea what
had just happened.
There seemed to be no earthly explanation
why these creatures would suddenly manifest
inside the incinerators, but as the detained
anomalies continued regenerating, a slightly
clearer picture of what exactly the Foundation
was dealing with began to emerge.
Every single one of the captured anomalies
kept regenerating, and upon getting to the
point that they were no-longer burn scarred,
the researchers studying the anomalous creatures
discovered that each one was identical to
a deceased D-Class from the Foundation’s
records.
They were physically and genetically identical
to the dead Class D Personnel.
Perfect copies, save for the fact that their
sole mission in life seemed to now be pure
and unmitigated aggression and violence.
Researchers wanted to gain greater insight
into the minds of these strange creatures
through the use of extensive psychological
evaluations and interviews.
It would turn out to be a very dangerous investigation.
A psychological researcher by the name of
Dr. Warren conducted an interview with one
of the SCP-2419-A instances in hopes of better
understanding their mindset.
This creature had been heard laughing not
long before the interview began, so it wasn’t
an unreasonable assumption to believe that
it could be capable of speech.
The interviewee was separated from Dr. Warren
by a thick pane of glass to prevent it from
indulging in any of its more violent urges.
The problem was that Dr. Warren and his assistant
researchers had severely underestimated what
these creatures were capable of doing to get
what they wanted.
Dr. Warren tried to begin the interview in
good faith.
He spoke calmly and politely to the creature
through the glass, attempting to remind it
of the person it once was.
The anomaly didn’t appear to be paying attention
to the doctor though, instead focusing on
pulling its own arm apart, and breaking the
bones within.
Dr. Warren began to think that the creatures
weren’t even sentient, if the only activity
they seemed to engage in was the wanton destruction
of themselves and others.
But underestimating them like this proved
to be a big mistake.
By removing the skin off of its arm, and whittling
its bones down to sharp edges, the anomaly
had transformed its arm into a makeshift knife.
Before anyone realized this, it had already
used its own jagged bones to break the glass
divider and attack Dr. Warren.
He perished not long after, after being stabbed
multiple times in his face and eyes and the
anomaly was forcefully taken back to its holding
cell.
Dr. Daniel Jennings, a senior researcher,
was then put on the case.
He released a chilling memo on the creatures
after his observation period ended.
It read:
“Before I came here, I worked as a prison
shrink.
Every person you met had a story bursting
with pain and sorrow.
Sometimes, those stories were about the pain
they suffered; sometimes, it was about the
pain they inflicted.
Some days you felt like everyone there was
a beautiful soul torn down by their circumstances
— other days, you'd find out what some of
them did and a part of you was glad they were
there to suffer for it.
But at the end of every day, I always told
myself: They're all humans.
They're all people.
They all deserve the same dignity, respect,
and love as everyone else.
No exceptions.”
Dr. Jennings goes on.
“I opened up with that anecdote only so
you could understand that what I'm about to
say is not said lightly: These things are
not people.
They are people-shaped monsters.
They are well beyond any definition of psychopathy.
Everything they do, they do to hurt, maim,
and kill.
I would pity them, but that would imply that
they're worth pitying.
Put them in a hole, then fill that hole with
concrete.
Better still: Throw them back into the incinerator
where you found them.
I doubt they'll even care.”
Following this string of unfortunate incidents,
containment procedures were put into place
to hopefully prevent anything that had happened
to the unlucky Foundation staff from happening
again.
The entire facility was fenced off, and was
constantly patrolled by MTF Beta-7, also known
as the Maz Hatters, a group specializing in
containing anomalies which present powerful
biological, chemical, or radiological dangers.
The furnaces that the anomalous creatures
emerged from remain lit at all times, with
workers checking and carrying out maintenance
on every single one, each day of the week.
Outside of this, the facility is essentially
a no-go zone.
Reinforced steel hatches cover the chutes,
and they are to forever remain bolted shut.
All because of that one terrifying day in
1975.
That was the day that the Summer Springs waste
disposal facility, which had been a valuable
asset to the Foundation for decades, instead
became classified as the Euclid-Class anomaly
SCP-2419.
It’s not uncommon for a Foundation asset
to one day become a dangerous anomaly requiring
containment, but the same question always
pops up after...
Why?
Why had a place that had been so valuable
to the Foundation suddenly become such an
active danger?
The answer, as is often the case, is contained
within the question.
Why would a waste disposal plant be so important
to the Foundation in the first place?
And more importantly, what else was going
on at the plant to make it such an area of
active importance for one of the most powerful
organizations in the entire world?
To put it simply, the plant allowed the Foundation
to dispose of something far more important
than mere waste material - it gave them what
they needed to better erase memories.
As you probably already know, the Foundation
makes liberal use of amnestics on those exposed
to anomalous material to make them forget
what they have seen and experienced, but these
elusive chemicals - many of which are sourced
from SCP-3000 - are an inexact science.
However, at the Summer Springs waste disposal
plant, researchers discovered an immensely
valuable alternative.
Much of what was disposed of in the incinerators
of Unit C were the bodies of dead D-Class
personnel.
Before being burned, autopsies were performed
on the bodies to make sure they were non-anomalous
- including the brain.
Back in the 1960s, while performing research
on the brains of the dead D-Classes, they
found a method of extracting and distilling
the positive memories of the dead, creating
a kind of “Happy Soup.”
When administered into someone who has undergone
amnestic treatment, this happy soup creates
positive false memories in their mind that
fills in those pesky blank spaces that are
often behind.
This was so useful that happy memories were
extracted from the minds of every single D-Class
corpse that passed through Unit C, totaling
well into the thousands by the time that the
first SCP-2419-A instances began to rise.
But as all happiness, joy, and love were removed
from the minds of the D-Classes, it seemed
that all that was left was pure hate, pain,
violence, and fury.
Feelings too intense and evil to destroy.
These were bodies imbued with a malice so
powerful that no fire could ever burn them
away.
They exist now with single-minded determination
to get out and destroy everything around them.
Everything.
Including the ones that made them, the SCP
Foundation itself.
And in the end, it’s only a matter of time
until they get out.
There are thousands of them in there, unable
to die, unable to stop.
The only thing keeping them in there is the
constant burning of the furnaces around them,
and those furnaces can’t burn forever.
The monsters lurking in SCP-2419 will outlive
the fire that surrounds them, because while
the furnaces they are contained in are hot,
the fires of hate that burn within SCP2419
entities are even more powerful.
And they know this.
They know they can’t be contained forever,
and that someday soon, they’ll be able to
emerge and exact their terrible revenge.
Those who must walk past the incinerators
may think they hear their screams echoing
out from within, but it’s not screaming
at all.
It’s laughter.
Now check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of the
HMS Wintersheimer” and “SCP-3999 - I Am
At The Center of Everything That Happens To
Me” for more Tales of Terror from the SCP
Foundation!